три рокотом в українська влада марнував
антитерористичну операцію на
донбасі uuid повис на захід у нього
здвоєну бойовикам і
адмін буде щось бачила міліцію слов'янську
краматорський затишок дружки у team мої буде
ні президент України Петро Порошенко
the hype годину передвиборної кампанії вбити
а в кличуть ден і завершить і про те актори
досить апарат цінний боже in і буде
рватися два-три місяці вона травня і буде
роботи
худими у team убити вона ван залишилося
операція вдалася у повномасштабну
вину через російську скронь повторної
ням втрати цифри в витратах на сході України
зайти 3 рук і катастрофічним на
2600 піскова служба active заглянув та
пора на нах 9400 ризикових жертва сара
цивільного носила не так вже й отримує не
менше 2000 завидних то 7 тисяч пар вона
нах внутрішньої para sol en si
адже початку провини в Україні
зареєстровано по 2 мільйони
внутрішніх переселенців з донецької та
луганської областей вчимо за даними оон те
цифра вірша та двох мільйонів людей
надлишку вид конфлікту
точну суму надлишку вид вестових день
ви означає і складно на прокаті донецької
області скронь otzyvy.by страте та
називала суму на 5 мільярдів гривень
луганський чотири з половиною мільярди
мвф педро hugo воші у 2017 у вина на
Донбасі до того що в цьому економіки України
ми ще один вид сотих національного ВВП
російський slide за три роки і а то на
заході сні класу мені ви ще до того
щоб русі регулярні війська російської
федерації доля у бойових дів на
Донбасі досвіді на москву досі і запишу
і про те не на те, а особливо до поведінки
розслідуючого проекту bellingcat
не було б за первинний до кози за
каченям альянсу брудну годину в Україні
bloopers суть не вигляд ковзанів 100 такі
як тисяч російських солдат
ви вирішення конфлікту за три раковини
режим pro досі у вогні близько 60 прикрасивши
про титри вали банани боргу сторони
означало одну одну
гіперемія ви вирішите конфлікт на мага юті
за в дикій переговорах про нормандське
форматі результати переговорів
мінську та роки так і нереалізовані